yeah underwater horror movie in January
January horror movie I know what you're
thinking I get it
[Music]
underwater so underwater is a horror
movie that Tate you want to know where
it takes place guess where it takes
place
yeah underwater the most creative title
bit on the nose takes place in the
Mariana Trench or the Marianas Trench
have heard both a place so deep in the
ocean that fewer people have been there
that have walked on the moon which is a
crazy thought and this facility starts
falling apart down there so the small
crew has to leave that facility go on
the ocean floor walk across the ocean
floor to another facility hopefully get
to safety all the wild there might be
monsters let me get right into it
because this movie actually got right
into it which I appreciate I mean you
meet Kristen Stewart and before you know
it this place is exploding and
collapsing in on itself is actually
quite intense and among that intense
scene I was like maybe this movie's not
gonna be garbage I mean that complete
garbage maybe maybe there's hope I
appreciate Thank You January horror
movie for just kind of getting into it
not wasting our time Kristen Stewart's
the main star of this movie like I said
it's a very small crew which also I like
when you have a claustrophobic horror
movie you know fewer people it makes for
better tone it makes for a more isolated
feeling but Kristen Stewart's good
because I've seen Kristen Stewart be
good she was goodness she's been good in
other things in fact she just look we're
gonna move past Twilight here because I
went through my face everyone in
Twilight sucks forever which then
YouTube happens as life happens you know
people grow they mature their
perspectives change and now I'm left
with the realization that if anyone on
earth was contractually obligated to
word vomit those Twilight scripts they
probably couldn't have done any better
yeah she was good in this movie so this
movie has good tone it's not like you've
never seen this movie before in terms of
tone or premise the initial facility
their end it's like collapsing in on
itself so a lot of times the waters up
to here which means no power a lot of
flashlights you know waters always
dripping from the ceiling everything's
what kind of reminded me I know you
think I'm gonna say alien I'm not though
also alien that kind of reminded me of
that movie Pandorum who's another real
surprise when that movie came out and
think I was gonna like that and I like
Pandorum so when I say I actually
enjoyed underwater take that into
consideration if you hate Pandorum who
knows maybe you'll hate this I mean
underwater is not as good as Pandora but
in terms of tone there was something
very familiar about this maybe was just
because I was surprisingly entertained
by this as well TJ Miller's
also in this movie I was like is he
gonna ruin the tone he really did I mean
he still has his TJ Miller isms he's
definitely the comic relief he kind of
reminded me of Hudson from aliens
he's the comic relief character and he
actually does work in this movie also a
couple of editing choices it was like I
don't know if you just rat a budget or
you're just trying to save time but a
couple of times it's just like I'm black
alright guys we got the door closed I'm
glad we made it to this room now how did
you make it to that room ah editing cuz
budget had to have been something like
that which to their credit they do make
that dollar stretch they actually use it
to their advantage one you don't see
this thing up there that's possibly
trying to kill them you don't ever get a
good shot of anything just quick
glimpses just the tail end of something
if it was deliberate great glad you know
that showing the monster actually makes
it less scary and if it was because of
budget this is one of those scenarios
where lack of money actually made for
something more creative also when
they're underwater walking it's very
dark and I imagine there's a lot of CGI
use cuz I don't think they took deep-sea
diving lessons I don't think James
Cameron's directing this one I don't
think it was later everyone needs to
learn this so I just assume CGI but in
the world where you're always kicking
dust up and it's that deep in that dark
it's always murky it's always murky it's
never bright it's really dark and so
anything's only ever half focused and
half blurry so I got the feeling the
consensus was we can use CGI here cuz it
doesn't really have to be clear yeah a
couple of jump scares yeah but they're
sci-fi jump scare for some reason to me
they feel different they're not
logistically there's the same thing
something jumps at the Cameron you
freaked out there's something about
sci-fi creature jump scare that feels
different than ghost in the bedroom jump
scare it was because it's a living thing
of course it's gonna jump at me ghosts
they don't have to do that kind a scared
you what was the point of that deck but
also this movie has a few moments of
genuine intensity I was like I don't
know who's gonna live and who's gonna
die and we'll see how it goes down again
the movie by his premise feels a bit
redundant it's not like this is the most
unique and original premise in Hollywood
history it's not even closed this is
about as cliche as it gets I think I saw
a three-second YouTube ad for it so when
I was sitting there waiting for this
movie to come on I was like okay let's
watch a movie that should have come out
between 1989 and 1997 bored twenties
money better late than never
well not lie to you by the end of this
movie I was like I was entertained I'll
say underwater was a fun time no
alcohol acquired if you're a fan of
claustrophobic monster horror especially
if it's underwater and you don't care
how cliche can get in parts I think you
might have fun with this that's all I
could say all right so underwater have
you seen it what do you think about it
are you looking forward to watching it
it's not even on your radar cuz you
didn't know it existed until just now or
what's your favorite claustrophobic
horror movie underwater or otherwise
whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you'd like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
say more
[Music]